when I look at this cultural revolution
that that we're going through and and
the way that every couple of years that
that pass brings us to and even more
aggressive imposition of revolutionary
ideas when I when I say Revolution I
mean that in the negative sense tearing
apart everything that has been inherited
that was any good and not claiming
everything we inherit is good but
tearing apart
first you know they began in the 1960s
first with God in scripture and then
from there to the destruction of the
idea of nation and family and finally
they've gotten to the elimination of the
ideas of man and woman and it look there
there is no end to this this this
aggressive critique of every inherited
idea it it will destroy us first to
misery and then to weakness and then to
dictatorship